hi I'm Kylie Jenner and this is the
hashtag probably when I fell backstage a
Vera Wang that was embarrassing
no one saw and I've got any pictures of
videos but I felt I was just standing in
place and my shoes were too small and
way too high and I just fell really hard
and everyone saw me so I was
embarrassing the Wardrobe that I was
most like to raid would probably be Kim
and Kanye's as I like wearing men's
clothes too and I just like their style
is inspired Taylor Lautner in Sharkboy
Peter Pan the boy who plays Peter Pan
the real-life version off the cartoon
and
Lil Wayne
moisturizer sunscreen and Kylie lip kit
my fitness inspiration is my assistant
Victoria she really inspires me workout
she kicks my butt tells me all the time
about it I don't think I've ever
finished a series ever in life but the
last series that I was watching was OJ
Simpson trial I didn't finish it
I don't think I will not that it wasn't
good it was great but I can't see the
finish series
I just feel most glamorous to my leg get
my makeup done I have like my hair for
bags and I just like feel really good
and confident
you